oh hell i don't know maybe you decide
you want to clean your room
and it's a hell of a mess and you're
working with the therapist and
you know he says look just open one of
the drawers and
look at it because you've been avoiding
it for five years just
that's all you have to do this week open
it and look at it
and you know on the one hand that's so
trivial and it's pathetic
but on the other hand no it's not and so
often the person will come back and say
well that i did it but it was just
stupid
it's like no it wasn't
your room isn't clean but you opened the
damn drawer and now it's time to give
yourself a pat on the back
and but to do that you have to admit in
some sense you have to
admit how pathetic you actually are you
know you have to admit how pathetic you
are before you can reward yourself
and that's okay because
that that patheticness well it's sort of
built in to your
to the fact that you're vulnerable you
know and you need
a small step and you need a reward
that's okay it's okay
that that's the case you know when you
see people what they'll do is they'll
say well that
you know that's just a good indication
of how useless i am
you know that that's all i can do
so they punish themselves well then you
have an opportunity you say to them look
there's two things going on
you can't clean up your room that's a
problem but you also can't reward
yourself properly so we need to take
that apart
and fix that so that you can reward
yourself properly
and that's also why you know when i
suggested to people that they clean up
the rooms the reason i did that was
because i actually knew how difficult
that is
because to get your room in order you
there's no way you can get your
surroundings in order without
simultaneously getting yourself in order
at least to some degree and it's exact
for exactly the reasons i just discussed
what you'll find is the reason the mess
is
there is because of psychological mess
you know assuming it's not you didn't
just move or something you know what i
mean there might be obvious situational
contributors but generally speaking
is the mess the external mess is
absolutely isomorphic with the in
individual mess and so it's really
powerful to order
and beautify something in your immediate
environs
it's unbelievably powerful to do that
you learn a tremendous amount
you also may find for example maybe your
family is dysfunctional
and part of the reason that your room is
such a bloody mess is because if you
ever took any steps to address it
they would punish you because as soon as
you start to clean up your room then you
cast a dim
light on their mess and so they see you
taking a step forward they're going to
whack you because
now you're an ideal that's judging them
so
you deal with someone who is in a
dysfunctional family and you
ask them to do something positive to
move forward and then you watch
the resistances that emerge and you've
got a picture of the pathology in the
family
and that can help the person start to
sort that through
because maybe they can say it like you
have to do a lot of negotiating and
thinking before this is a possibility
but maybe you say well look you have to
have a talk with your mom
you have to say look mom i'm doing
something good here
and your reaction is to punish me
what the hell is up with that now
that's a complicated conversation and
maybe you have to start with something
even smaller than that but
you get the point you know these things
aren't simple
they're not simple at all and luckily
though they're right in front of you you
can in fact
do it and you'll learn a lot from doing
it
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed peace